Okay.
Uh,
the subject is special relativity
and right at the end of the last class,
uh,
I had written down this factor gamma and
gamma is the key thing which tells you
how relativistic,
uh,
you are.
Gamma is equal to one over the
square root of one minus V squared.
Oversee squared.
Uh,
and we talked about this
factor a little bit.
Uh,
if the oversea is equal to
zero or approaches zero,
then gamma obviously is one.
And when gamma's one,
that's the Newtonian case,
then everything is just
like Newton's laws said.
Okay.
Uh,
on the other hand,
as v oversee goes to,
goes to one.
That is to say as the velocity
approaches the speed of light,
this gamma factor goes to infinity
because one minus one in the denominator,
that's your own the denominator.
So the thing has to go to infinity.
And then all these bizarre relativistic
effects start taking place.
And the one we talked about in particular,
uh,
came about from an example
of how this gamma is used,
namely that the relativistic mass,
uh,
is equal to gamma times.
The rest mass,
which is the Newtonian mass.
And obviously if dammit equals one,
then then the Newtonian
mass is equal to the,
then,
then the mass is equal to the
Newtonian mass and you're,
you're a Newton's laws
and everything is fine.
Uh,
when the velocity,
uh,
approaches the speed of light,
then this total relativistic
mass goes to infinity.
Uh,
the consequence of which is that
you can no longer accelerate
regardless of how much,
uh,
so no more acceleration regardless
of how much force is applied because,
uh,
force equals mass times acceleration.
And if the mass is infinite,
then any amount of force will
not give you an acceleration.
And acceleration is
the change in velocity.
And so the consequence of this is that
you can't go faster than the speed of
light.
Uh,
it's also another side
consequence of this.
Sorry.
Yeah,
it was,
oh,
excellent.
Yes.
Ascott
v okay.
V Is the velocity that
something is traveling.
There's no escape philosophy
here at the moment.
Um,
there are all kinds of
different V's floating around,
so it's important to keep them straight.
Yeah.
Can't,
you can't go faster than
the speed of light aside.
A comment from this is that photons,
particles of light,
which obviously by definition
do go at the speed of light,
have to have a zero rest mass.
Uh,
because otherwise they'd have,
they'd end up having infinite
mass and infinite energy,
which isn't,
which isn't a physical.
So,
uh,
photons which go at the speed of light,
for which gamma is therefore infinite,
have to have em,
this,
this little m zero here equal to zero.
So you have zero times infinity
and that can equal a finite number.
Otherwise they'd have infinite,
uh,
energy.
Yes.
If we're talking about
the wow factor or like
at the moment what I'm talking
about is velocity as a,
uh,
as a speed.
So I'm talking about the
magnitude of the velocity.
And you can tell actually that that's
the case because it comes in as the,
as the velocity squared.
So even if it's a vector,
when you square it,
that gives you a scalar quantity.
Okay.
So let me go on from,
from here and uh,
talk about an intermediate case.
We've talked about V equals zero.
We've talked about vehic.
We'll see.
Uh,
let me talk about an intermediate case
and the particular intermediate case,
and this'll show up on your problem set.
This is the thing we
didn't get to on Thursday,
uh,
is what's called the post
Newtonian approximation.
Yeah.
This is when you're just a
tiny little bit relativistic.
So v oversee or more properly v squared
over c squared is small but not zero.
And here a little mathematical concept
that may have flashed before your eyes
when you were in 11th grade
or something comes in,
which is the series expansion.
Uh,
we won't do the mathematics of this,
but,
but here it is,
uh,
if you take one plus epsilon,
and I should say epsilon is a,
uh,
used by mathematicians
to mean something small,
famous mathematician named Erdish
used to refer to children as epsilons.
Uh,
that seems to be carrying
it a little bit too far.
Uh,
but,
uh,
this is how mathematicians think.
So epsilon,
in this case,
it is something that's much,
much less than one a.
And if you take one plus epsilon,
so that's a number that's
slightly greater than one.
Uh,
and uh,
you take it to the anthropology,
you can then expand this,
uh,
as a series and the series goes like this,
one plus n times epsilon
plus a bunch of other terms,
each of which is multiplied
by a higher power of epsilon.
So there's a term in epsilon squared and
there's a terminal epsilon cube and so
forth.
And this is an infinite series.
Uh,
but the thing is if epsilon small
than epsilon squared is even smaller.
So if Epsilon's already small and,
and times epsilon is pretty small,
then epsilon squared is far smaller
than that epsilon cube yet smaller and
these,
uh,
are negligible.
And so the approximation is
okay.
One plus epsilon to the nth power is
approximately equal to one plus an epsilon
if epsilon is much,
much less than one.
Okay.
So here's what we're going to do.
We're going to use this series
expansion and we're going to generate a
expressions for some things
in particular the mass,
but some other things too where the
one is the Newtonian term and the thing
represented by this and epsilon,
which is much smaller is a correction
to the Newtonian term and is the first
sign that things are
becoming relativistic.
So this is in this context going to be
a Newtonian term and this is the post
knew Tony and
approximation.
Okay.
Uh,
oh.
So let's,
uh,
let's just do an example.
Um,
uh,
let's,
let's think about the motion of the earth,
the Earth's orbit around
the Sun Earth orbit.
Uh,
you may recall from the last section of
the class how fast the earth moves to
about three times 10 to
the four meters per second,
30 kilometers a second.
Hey,
the speed of light is three times
10 to the eight meters per second.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
v squared oversee squared is equal
to three times 10 to the four,
over three times 10 to the eight
squared is 10 to the minus eight.
And so that quantity,
which is going to turn out to be the post
Newtonian effect is one part intentive
the eight for the Earth's orbit.
And so pretty small considering,
uh,
that we think that nine is equal to 10.
Uh,
something in the eighth decimal place
isn't going to do a lot of damage,
so it's not a particularly relativistic,
uh,
situation.
All right,
so now I want to go back and I want,
that's just an aside.
I want to go back and apply
this approximation to gamma.
Gamma is equal to one
over one minus V squared.
Oversee squared,
the whole thing to the one half power,
that one minus v squared over
square to the minus one half power.
I got to get a better pen.
Sorry about that.
Uh,
and now this can be expanded.
This can be expanded in
just this kind of way.
Uh,
the first term is one,
uh,
Epsilon is minus v squared,
oversee squared.
N is minus a half minus
times a minus is a positive.
So this is plus one half v squared
over c squared plus additional terms,
the first of which is v squared.
Over c squared squared,
which in the case of the earth
would be 10 to the minus 16.
So it would be a vastly smaller still.
So we ignore that.
Okay.
And so that,
uh,
and so you can substitute this for gamma,
in situations where v is kind of small.
For example,
let's go back to this mass.
Uh,
equation.
One plus one,
half v squared.
Oversee Square.
This is the total mass.
Now,
oh,
let's separate these terms out.
M Zero,
that's the Newtonian term.
And now here's a post
Newtonian approximation,
one half m Zero v squared
divided by c square.
Okay.
High school physics experts.
Do you recognize this term?
Kinetic energy?
Absolutely right?
This is from high school physics.
The kinetic energy.
That is to say the energy,
uh,
in the motion of this object.
So what is this whole term?
This whole term is the kinetic energy.
So M is equal to the Newtonian rest mass
plus the kinetic energy divided by c
squared.
Now,
you'll recall that he oversee
squared is equal to an,
so this is the mass equivalent,
okay.
Of the kinetic energy.
So given this nice relativistic idea
that mass and energy are interchangeable.
Well here it is.
Here's the kinetic energy
expressed in terms of mass.
Uh,
and so this little equation and
equals am not gamma has a variety of
consequences.
When v Oversea v squared oversee
squared really goes to zero,
then it's just Newton.
It just says mass equals mass.
Uh,
because gamma is equal to two one and
that expresses an important Newtonian
concept that the mass of something is
an intrinsic property of that object,
which doesn't change,
which is how things are in Newton,
but not how things are relativistically.
Uh,
in the other extreme where v squared
over c squared approaches one,
this equation expresses
the fact that light,
uh,
the speed of light as
this is the speed limit.
And in the Post Newtonian case where V
squared over ski squared is small but not
zero,
this is same expression,
expresses the fact that equals MC squared.
Yeah.
So all three of these concepts
come out of the same equation.
It's this kind of thing,
uh,
that makes physicists say things like,
the theory of relativity.
It's incredibly beautiful.
Uh,
it's hard to know.
I realize it's hard to
know what that means.
You know,
what makes a piece of
mathematics beautiful.
Uh,
and it's kind of when you get a situation
like this where a simple mathematical
concept sort of spawns all kinds
of new and unexpected ideas,
depending on how you look at it and that
they all kind of come together as one.
I have this vivid memory
in graduate school.
I was sitting in a class,
you know,
and the professor was doing
the thing that professors do.
He was writing down all kinds of
miscellaneous information really,
really fast,
uh,
from,
relativity theory and nuclear physics.
All sorts of stuff was
going up on the board.
I was doing the thing that students do
where you desperately try and write it
all down so that you can then go back
and figure out what the hell he was
talking about later.
Uh,
and suddenly in the midst of
this rather typical class,
uh,
I realized what was happening that in
about 20 minutes he was going to put all
this stuff together and prove Chandra,
say cars limit.
We talked about Chandra
cars limit a week or so ago.
That's the limit whereby a white dwarf
can't be bigger than 1.4 times the mass
of the sun or it continues to collapse.
And I suddenly saw where
all this was going.
I sort of wrote down in my notebook,
Chandra and underlined it and put my
pencil down and then I just watched for 20
minutes.
It was great.
It was the only thing
I can compare it to is,
is,
is listening to,
to a great piece of music because it
kind of unfolds in time and you see where
it's going and,
and it's just a great feeling.
So,
uh,
don't be condescending to the physics
majors when they're working like hell on
those problem sets late on a Thursday
night because they have access to realms
of aesthetic experience,
uh,
that you can only imagine.
Uh,
but perhaps it's true.
It's true.
I promise.
Uh,
but you have to work hard to
get there and ask questions.
And so,
uh,
at this point,
let's do the question thing.
Uh,
here's what I'd like to do a
talk to the people around you.
Introduce yourself to
the people around you.
Groups of two,
three or four will do fine.
Uh,
and uh,
come up in consultation with your
neighbors with a question to ask.
Now,
this could either be a
question of something that
you guys don't about what I've
said or something where
the question if answered,
would deepen your understanding
beyond what I've said.
So take a couple minutes,
uh,
talk to your neighbors,
make a friend,
think of a question and,
uh,
in a couple minutes time
we'll regroup and a,
I'll answer some of the questions if
you're particular question doesn't end up
being answered,
you know,
handed in at the end so that I
know what you were thinking of.
Uh,
and uh,
and so definitely write them down.
Uh,
and we'll,
we'll,
we'll try this out.
Let's see.
Let's see how this goes.
So introduce yourself to your neighbors,
uh,
and come up with a question.
And when you have it,
put your hand up and ask it
will come around and ask.
All right,
I've now heard the same question twice.
Uh,
so let me answer it and then we'll,
uh,
ask for other things.
The same question which has been asked
in a couple of different ways is what is
mass?
That's an excellent question because it's
awfully hard to parse what's going on,
uh,
with this m nod and this other kind of
m and stuff if you don't know what the
concept means.
So that's a,
that's a really good question.
What mass mass is defined.
You can think of it this way.
What is mass?
Uh,
mass is defined as from this
equation in a certain sense.
F equals m a,
it tells you for a given object how
hard it is to move or more precisely how
hard it is to accelerate.
So higher mass,
okay.
Requires greater force
to,
uh,
accelerate by a certain amount.
It
a property of an object and it tells
you how much it resists being pushed
around.
Uh,
it's sometimes referred
to as inertial mass.
For this reason,
it's,
it's an expression of
the object's inertia,
how much it resists being accelerated.
Uh,
and so in Newtonian physics,
this is purely a property
of the object itself.
You can say,
uh,
if you've got a basketball or if you
got a car or something that the car has
more mass than the basketball.
Why?
Because if I go to,
I have a basketball,
I don't,
uh,
alright.
Car a car has the lectern
has more mass than the,
uh,
than the little piece of cardboard here.
Cause if I apply force to the cardboard,
I can move it.
And if I apply the same amount of force
to the lecture and I move it a whole lot
less.
And so what is the difference
between those two things?
Since the force applied is the same.
The difference is that this
one has a whole lot more mass.
And in Newtonian physics,
the mass is a property of the object.
In Einsteinian physics,
there is something that's the property
of the object that it's rest mass.
But the inertial mass,
the amount by which it resists
being pushed is also a property,
not just of the rest mass,
but also if it's motion.
So that if this thing were moving at a
large fraction of the speed of light and
I applied,
uh,
some kind of forced to it,
it wouldn't move nearly
as much as it does.
Oh,
it wouldn't change it's motion nearly
as much as it does when it's standing
still.
And so,
uh,
mass is the inertial mass of the thing
varies depending on how fast it's moving.
So that's uh,
uh,
that's an important question,
for understanding this.
Uh,
let's see.
Yes.
Um,
so does that mean that your
honor scanning in motion,
you're going to have
the same effect on it?
No,
you're not going to have the same effect
on it because if the object in motion
is going to have a little
extra piece to its mass.
Okay.
Very,
very small effect.
In fact,
if you try this on the earth itself,
which is moving at 30 kilometers a second,
that effect is going to be
one part in 10 to the eight.
So that's what we
calculated before where we,
uh,
where was it?
Uh,
yeah.
Here it is.
That's this purple part here.
You Calculate v squared over c squared.
That's 10 to the minus eight.
So it's a different,
if something moving even as
fast as 30 kilometers a second,
which is pretty fast,
this difference is only going to be
actually one half of one part in 10 to the
eight.
Uh,
so it's,
uh,
it's a hard thing to see.
Now the place you can see this stuff is
in particle accelerators because there
you can take subatomic particles and
accelerate them to very close to the speed
of light and then you see
these very dramatic effect.
Yes,
yes,
that's correct.
You cannot stop something that's going
at the speed of light because the force
you'd need to accelerate it,
which could either be making it
faster or slower would be infinite.
Uh,
but that's why photons don't
have any rest mass at all.
That statement that you made only
applies to something which has none,
zero,
greater than zero rest mass,
and they never go to the
speed of light could,
you can't get them that fast.
You need an infinite amount of
force to get it to go that fast.
Photons are a different story.
And of course if you stop a photon,
it disappears because if it's
going less than the speed of light,
then it's got no energy because it's
a finite gamma times zero rest mass.
Yes.
All right.
The weird time stuff
you always hear about.
Excellent.
Uh,
yeah.
Okay.
A couple of other Lawrence transformations
time is equal to gamma times,
times zero a,
this is time dilation.
The faster you go,
the slower your clock works.
This is the origin of all that nice
science fiction where you get on a rocket
ship,
you go close to the speed of light,
it go somewhere,
your turnaround,
you've come back.
Uh,
your clocks are running slow,
so it only takes a year and
your time and you come back in.
Everybody,
you know,
it's a hundred years have passed,
all your friends are dead and so forth.
Uh,
so that's a whole science fiction thing.
There's also lake contraction
that looks like this.
Uh,
take the pen,
put it in motion,
uh,
make that motion at some substantial
fraction of the speed of light.
It gets shorter.
Amazing.
Uh,
we'll talk more about
this in a little while.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
These are these,
these things with the gamma's in them.
They're collectively known as
the Lorentz transformations.
Uh,
that's just a name.
and,
okay.
And these are the ways in
which basic properties,
space time mass change,
uh,
with philosophy.
Yeah.
So with the equation equals m not get
times gamma am not if the intrinsic math,
yes.
No,
no,
no.
M M not,
yes.
Let me think.
Am Not,
is the intrinsic mass
m is the inertial mass.
Okay.
That's a way of thinking about it.
So if something's traveling at a very
small would mean that B squared overseas
guard was close to zero.
Yes.
Which means that the inertial
mass be close to them.
No.
Uh,
if it goes,
so you were right up to the very end.
Remember how this works.
Gamma is equal to one over the
square root of one minus p squared.
Oversee squid.
If v oversee goes to zero,
gamma goes to one.
And in that case,
the inertial mass is equal
to the intrinsic mass.
Okay.
And if it's going faster than the
inertial mass is bigger than the intrinsic
mass,
the intrinsic mass is usually
referred to as the rest mass.
Ah,
that's the second term
of the series expansion.
One over one minus V squared overseas
squared to the one half power expands to
be one plus one half v squared.
Oversee squared plus other terms.
Here's the first term,
that's the rest mass because we're going
to multiply this by amp and this is
then the kinetic energy
divided by c square.
It's the second term.
Uh,
yeah,
the rest mass doesn't change.
If v squared over c squared goes to zero,
what happens is the kinetic
energy goes to zero,
which is exactly what you want it to do.
Yes.
Um,
how does,
uh,
how has momentum,
how has momentum could serve
when something's relativistic?
Excellent.
There is an equation of
relativistic momentum,
uh,
and it's that thing that's conserved,
which is different from am times times
ve because ve behaves differently and m
behaves differently and you can work
out exactly where all the gamma's go in
that.
And I don't remember it
off the top of my head,
but there is a quantity that is conserved,
but it doesn't look quite the same as
the new Tony and quantity in the limit
where the velocity is small,
it reduces down the first term
of that series is m times v.
Oh yeah.
Yes sir.
Would you define
acceleration?
How then do you define for us?
Yeah.
Okay.
So this gets a little,
this gets a little bit circular,
right?
Uh,
okay.
Force force,
you can define it either way.
Forces the thing that it
forces the ability to do work.
That's the technical definition.
Uh,
force ability,
uh,
to do work.
And then work also has
a technical definition.
The problem with these things is you
kind of do act in term if you're just
defined them all the
way around the circle,
they do tend to come back and
bite themselves in detail.
Uh,
I agree with that.
but,
uh,
forces also related to energy.
You know,
how much energy is required
to exert a certain force.
So all these things,
all these things interrelate.
Uh,
but it is definitely true that there's
a circularity to the definitions if you
follow them all the way around.
So if you keep asking
that kind of question,
I'm going to go around until I
get back where I started from.
Yes.
Why is the speed of like constant in all
frames of reference that's problem to,
of your problem set?
Uh,
and uh,
I'll come,
I'll,
I'll say a few.
That's an insufficient answer,
but I'll,
uh,
I'll come back and say a little
bit more about that in a minute.
Uh,
yes.
Um,
we were just a little bit confused
with the original transformation,
how in most cases that
transforms to equals MC squared.
Um,
could you show that?
Yeah.
So let's go back and take
another look at that.
All right.
So here's what I'm going to do.
First of all,
I'm going to take gamma this
quantity and I'm going to expand it.
This is equal to gamma and
now I'm going to expand it.
That gives me one plus a half
p squared overseas quick.
Um,
let's see.
What have I done with my,
uh,
the pieces of paper are
getting out of order here.
Ah,
here it is.
So inertial mass is equal to
the rest mass times gamma.
So now I'm going to substitute
in this approximation for gamma.
And then I'm going to multiply
m zero through both terms.
So this is,
so the inertial mass is equal to the
Newtonian mass plus a term that looks like
this.
Uh,
m one half MV squared is in,
uh,
in Newtonian terms of the
kinetic energy and I and it,
and it appears here divided by c squared.
And so a way you can write this is that
the inertial mass is equal to the rest
mass plus the Connecticut can the
kinetic energy divided by c squared.
And that is an example of the fact that
energy divided by c squared is an ex,
is another way of expressing mass.
Why?
Why is it not a prominent energy overseas
and literally Algebraic that Rbm am
not,
oh,
which am are you talking about?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's not here and it's em over here.
And so if somebody asks,
actually you're the now the second
person who's asked this question.
So I better answer it explicitly.
Uh,
W I answered the question,
what is mass?
Uh,
what's energy?
e equals m c squared.
So what do I mean by this?
A M this is the,
uh,
inertial mass.
So,
uh,
that's m which is equal to,
in this case,
Amnon plus kinetic energy,
oversee squared.
And notice the difference here,
this is one kind of energy.
This is kinetic energy.
That's the energy in,
uh,
that's the energy contained in the motion.
Another way you could write this
is the arrest energy over c square.
So He,
here is the total energy and there are
two kinds of energies being expressed
here.
There's a rest energy divided by c squared
and there's a kinetic energy divided
by c squared.
But in the new Tony in case you think
of them as two completely different
things,
whereas in the relativistic case,
there do two manifestations
of the same thing.
And they add to make the inertial mass,
yes
today or a fraction of,
of see what something needs to
be traveling on earth for us to,
for there to be a perceptible.
Okay.
So how fast you have to go to have
a perceptible relativistic effect.
That depends how good your instrument are.
If you,
if you've got something
that can perceive a,
that can measure a velocity or an energy
or a mass to eight decimal places,
then it doesn't have to go so fast.
If you have something that's a fairly
crude than it has to go much faster.
Uh,
but I should say special relativity,
these Lorentz transformation have been
measured upside down and backwards in
the,
in the laboratory,
this works too many,
many decimal places.
Uh,
uh,
here's an example.
If you take subatomic
particles that are unstable,
that decay,
they have a half life.
So half of them will decay
in 10 seconds or something,
and you take those particles and you
accelerate them to a large fraction of the
speed of light.
It takes much longer for them to decay.
Uh,
because they're going so
fast in their time clock,
slow down.
A one manifestation of this is,
uh,
there is this kind of unstable particle
that's created at the top of the
atmosphere.
These things are called nuance.
What happens is cosmic rays come in,
they plast the top of the atmosphere.
They make these mew on things.
The mew ons propagate close to the
speed of light and they arrive at Earth.
And you can measure if you have
a little [inaudible] detector,
nevermind what the heck have you on is.
But imagine that you have something that
could detect it on earth and you see a
whole bunch of these things
caused by cosmic rays.
Uh,
but if you ask how long did it take them
to get from the top of the atmosphere
down to where your mew on detector is,
it's much,
much longer than their decay time.
So you really shouldn't
see any of them at all.
But you do see them.
And the reason is because they're
going a close to the speed of light.
Uh,
and so this is,
uh,
these effects are observed and measured.
Two great accuracy in,
in the laboratory and in
astrophysical situations,
yes,
faster than the speed of light.
Well,
you'd have,
uh,
you'd have super infinite mass.
Uh,
this would be this,
this,
this would not be good.
Uh,
well,
okay,
so let us imagine what
the equations would,
would do.
What,
what happened is as you go
faster than the speed of light,
if you try and slow down
toward the speed of light,
you'd have to have the same problem.
Uh,
that is to say would take you're
more and more effort to slow down,
to close to the speed of light.
And the consequence of this is that
if you're fastened speed of light,
you can't slow down to the speed of
light or slower than that height.
There are hypothetical particles.
This doesn't exist in the real world,
but they're hypothetical
particles that do this.
These are called [inaudible].
Uh,
they have the odd effect that
they go backwards in time,
uh,
because again,
if you believe the equations,
uh,
right time dilation,
t equals gamma times t naught.
Now look at Gamma Square root of
one minus v squared over c square.
So this is awkward.
Uh,
if v is bigger than C,
this is a square root of a negative
number that becomes imaginary,
right?
Square root of n square
root of a negative number,
a hard to do.
Uh,
so this becomes imaginary.
So your time access becomes imaginary
and all sorts of very bad things start to
happen to you.
Uh,
yeah.
Yes.
So as your mass increases with philosophy,
the particle or the entity have
a greater gravitational effect.
Ah,
just to have a greater
gravitational effect.
Excellent question.
That's the next lecture.
Cause that's general relativity.
And what you're doing is you're assuming
that Newtonian gravity is correct,
Newtonian,
Newtonian gravity.
Gravity is a force
proportional to the mass.
Turns out,
and this is one of the things that
led Einstein to his theory of general
relativity.
Turns out that relativistically it's that,
uh,
gravity should not be
thought of as a force at all.
Uh,
and there's a whole different
way of thinking about it.
And,
and your question has to be in
a kind of Zahn sands unasked.
Uh,
we'll,
we'll get to that.
We,
we,
we will,
we will get to that.
But the point is that in,
in relativistic theory,
gravity is not a force anymore.
And so the question doesn't
arise in quite the same way.
Yes.
Sorry,
you were mentioning that energy here.
Total energy [inaudible] equal to
yeah,
he is equal to m not oversee
squared plus k e yeah.
You have to put,
you have to get the c
squared in the right place.
That's basically a unit
conversion overseas.
Uh,
no
is equal to uh,
uh,
c squared,
m not plus k.
E.
Basically what I've done
is I've multiplied this
equation by csquared on both
sides.
Yes.
What,
what is,
what are the implications
for like what time is it?
Well,
this is the right,
so what are the implications for what
time is this is the big stumbling block
from a philosophical point
of view to all of this stuff.
Turns out time isn't absolute.
Uh,
that is to say,
uh,
one has the feeling as we go
through our everyday life that,
you know,
my watch and your Ma Watch or kind of
measuring more or less the same thing.
The extent that there are accurate,
uh,
to do so.
So if we have identical,
perfectly accurate watches and we go
about our daily life and come back,
they're going to read the same time at
the end if they read the same time at the
beginning,
because time moves the same
way for me as it does for you.
This turns out to be false.
And so time is not an absolute,
an absolute quantity.
Neither is,
neither is space for that matter,
cause length changes also,
uh,
this is quite disturbing.
Uh,
and the reason it's so disturbing to
us is our brains have evolved in a
situation where we're
always moving really,
really slowly compared
to the speed of light.
And therefore you don't have to worry
about this stuff in everyday life down to
some factor of 10 to the minus 12.
Uh,
and uh,
but nevertheless,
it turns out to be true that time.
Time does not take off in an absolute way.
And this is why people get so freaked out
by this stuff because it seems counter
to everyday experience.
Uh,
but it can be measured and,
and it turns out,
and it turns out to be true.
So the Newtonian case,
what we're used to in
the way our brains work,
it turns out to be only an approximation
of the way things things really are.
There are other things that are
conserved no matter how fast you go.
And we can get to that at some,
at some point,
but time isn't one of them.
Yes.
Why is the speed of
light this magic number?
Uh,
okay.
So,
uh,
the fact that there is a magic number,
comes out of this kind of equation because
when this quantity is equal to one,
bad things start to happen
and all the equations blow up.
The fact that it is the speed of light
that happens to be that in that equation
is because light,
uh,
consists of particles with zero rest
mass and a particle at zero rest mass has
to have this thing go to infinity
or it doesn't exist at all.
Why?
Why,
why?
Why is the world this way that I know.
Seriously,
that's what you're asking.
And it's a good question.
And I can't answer it.
Uh,
you know,
because this is where
physics turns into it.
Seriously.
This is where physics turns into theology.
Uh,
you can't all the,
all you can say from scientists
that this is the way it works.
You can't answer the why question.
Uh,
you gotta talk to my colleagues in
some other department about that one.
I'm sorry,
because it's,
it's the question one would
really like to know the answer to,
right?
Uh,
but that one I can't,
I can't,
I can't cope with yes.
Enters the black hole
across the event horizon.
I've heard that oftentimes.
Ah,
okay.
So the question
is,
uh,
can like go into orbit around
a black hole basically.
And the answer is yes,
it can.
And then the next part
of the question was,
uh,
how does that work if it
doesn't have any mass?
You're asking the same question he did
over there because what keeps it in orbit
is gravity.
And if you reject the view
that gravity is a force,
then that question
doesn't become important.
And,
and we'll,
as I say,
we'll talk about that later.
So that again is a question that pops up
because you're thinking of gravity is a
force.
Yes.
Not to say why is it is why it is,
but
how is it derived?
Ah,
okay.
Uh,
so let me,
uh,
let me,
go on with the presentation in the last
couple of minutes of the class here.
Here's,
so let me ask your question
in a different way.
Here's what a pro,
why did Einstein think this up?
What a crazy ass thing to do,
right?
Why not?
You know,
there's little discrepancies
when things are moving at the,
at a high speeds,
but who the heck cares?
It's hard to measure things at high speed.
Why not just stick with Newton,
which has done very well for
two and a half centuries.
Here was the problem and
the late 19th century,
there were a whole series of experiments,
all of which one way or another
had the same consequence,
namely that light.
The speed of light,
uh,
is the same in all for all observers.
Okay?
Uh,
that's extraordinarily weird.
It's not obvious immediately
why that's so weird,
but,
but let me try and explain it.
Here's,
here's a guy,
and uh,
let's say he's a baseball
pitcher and he's throwing a ball.
So here's the ball and it's
moving this way at some velocity,
which we'll call v one and you're
down here or over here somewhere,
it doesn't really matter.
You're down here and you've got a radar
gun and you measure the velocity of that
baseball.
How fast is it going?
Well,
if he throws it at v one and
you're at rest with respect to him,
then you measure [inaudible].
Now supposing we put our picture
on top of a moving train,
all right?
And the train is moving
at some other velocity.
V Two.
Uh,
so the guys on top of the train,
he throws it a hundred miles an hour.
The trains moving at a
hundred miles an hour.
You're standing next to the
track with your radar gun,
how fast you measure
that baseball to move.
Well,
you measure a total velocity,
which is the sum of the velocity of the
baseball with respect to the train and
the train with respect to you.
Okay,
that seems pretty clear.
But now supposing this guy,
instead of throwing a baseball,
he's got a flashlight,
so he's got some lights for us,
some light source and the light is moving
at the speed of light because that's
the speed that like moves.
Uh,
and uh,
and you've got sub device down here
which measures how fast that light moves
along and he's standing at rest with you
and you measure the speed of light and
it comes out to be c,
not surprisingly the same speed of light.
Now let's put the guy on the train.
Here he is moving at v two or any V.
You would expect that the speed of light
that this guy measures down here would
be c Plus v two,
right?
Because it would be the speed of light
with respect from the flashlight with
respect to the train plus the speed
of the train with respect to you,
you would expect it to be
c Plus v two but it isn't.
It's C v Total equals c not c Plus v two
very weird.
The speed of light is the same.
No matter how fast you're
moving relative to the source.
You could be moving at 99% of the speed
of light toward a light source and it
would not be coming at you at
1.99 times the speed of light.
It would be coming towards
you at the speed of light.
You could have a friend who's standing
still and you would both measure the same
speed of that light,
even though you're moving really
fast compared to your friends.
Very strange.
And there were a whole
series of experiments,
uh,
the most famous of which is something
called the Michelson Morley experiment,
which one way or another
demonstrated that this was the case,
what to do.
And what Einstein did was he said,
hmm,
okay.
Uh,
various things were tried,
the experiments were wrong,
the equations were slightly screwy.
Who knows?
Uh,
but I'd started talking,
I'd stage great genius was to
take this seriously and to say,
okay,
something is really screwed
up with philosophies.
What is velocity?
Velocity is space over time,
miles per hour.
Therefore,
uh,
so space and time are messed up when
you get close to the speed of light.
Now,
of course,
it also has to be true that
when you're going slowly,
uh,
the original Newtonian result is recover.
So this is your problem set.
I have written down the relativistic
formula for the addition of velocities and
your problem set is going to be to use
that series expansion to demonstrate that
in the Newtonian limits you get this.
And in the,
uh,
limit where one or the other of those
velocities is the speed of light.
Uh,
you get this,
uh,
so,
you'll see the Algebra
is actually not so bad.
Uh,
and that's what prompted Einstein to go
on this whole rampage generating all of
these gamma's and so forth
was the experimental evidence,
uh,
that,
there's a serious problem with velocities.
Okay,
we got to stop.